the Joe Rogan experience and then Mike
Pence is holding Bible study classes for
the first time in a hundred years in the
White House what yeah really and women
aren't allowed to read what yes no no
women read the Bible there this is for
real and when the women are not teaching
there's no women teaching these Bible
study no it doesn't man he doesn't like
dinner with that mama there no no women
next to him at dinner Mike Pence must be
an animal just trying to keep it
together and just backed up just shocked
and yeah just gotta keep boy no dinner
with women no women
Mike Pence sponsors White House Bible
study led by anti LGBTQ anti women
extremists this is real ah
this is what we gotta be careful for
folks we've got to be careful of this
this guy could be President and that
ain't no better this is this guy is
[ __ ] radical radical fundamentalist
Christianity yeah boy whoo you see that
little bit bigger what does it say Bible
study group led by Ralph drollinger
an extremist who says LGBTQ people are
illegitimate Secretary of State nominee
Mike Pompeo Attorney General Jeff
Sessions and education secretary Betsy
Davos attended the weekly sessions in
Washington while drollinger claims he
doesn't tell members he's advised in the
past how to vote he notes that he would
in quotes put the blueprint on the
engineer seat on the train people look
to their faith is a source of guidance
and inspiration and LGBTQ people and our
family and friends are no different
drill injures brand of faith however
seeks to drive a wedge between the LG
that LGBT I think first of all how did
trans people get locked in with queer
people or gay people isn't that a
different thing it is I think they're
just all marginalized marginally Arabs
yeah
but they form do you know there's a to
an A+ do you know that one oh yes now
it's a and a plus this is like a this is
an abbreviated list but if you really
want to be completely not inclusive you
have to include
sexual people as well they feel
marginalized because they're not trans
they're not gay they're not straight
they're just not sex wait why cute queue
for queer wear but why is that different
than gay and Lazard okay I don't know
what is queer I don't know I thought
that men rights in them they evil right
now are screaming at us I know they're
saying is engendered [ __ ] I know
cisgender white white privilege [ __ ]
pretty well um I don't know what queue
why that is different why what is queer
what is the definite what it's just cuz
we're used to be just gang gay right so
Google what is the queue and LGBTQ and
then let's get into a and a plus this is
a sexual and is a plus by the way a huge
thanks I got a huge gift goodie bag can
I say thanks to the roots of fight guys
oh there's a great song on right no
that's crazy
she sure is sure we didn't even plan
them she's not playing this freezing I
came home to a bunch of free [ __ ] okay
LGBT g/l or GLBT hmm what is initialism
initialism I never saw that were before
that stands for lesbian gay bisexual
transgender to recognize this inclusion
a popular variant adds the cue for those
who identify as queer or are questioning
their sexual identity that makes you
like I'm not sure I'm not sure it's Andy
Dick yeah I might be gay it might be I
might be I'm not sure at least that's an
answer its fence sitters yeah I'm here
I'm there
they should have f24 fence it and my
genders whatever yeah what is it move me
a fluid gender fluid that's my favorite
you're a girl one day a boy the next day
I had somebody email me to they said at
work they said you know you can pick
your gender for emails for company
emails so he like this person picked a
gender he's like I think I'm going to do
this and I said what if your gender is
changing I think you should send them an
email every day
so be like today man yeah yeah he's like
I'm gonna try it see what happens what
is it they can't say [ __ ] I guess they
can't no you can't say [ __ ] all you have
to do just keep a straight face yeah
today identifies a woman you literally
can do whatever you want definitely yeah
which I mean and then people argue that
you should have the right to do that to
change whatever you want I guess I mean
it's not convenient for everyone but I
guess you can yeah I guess you can it's
not the worst thing in the world no but
when when do we call nonsense hmm yeah I
guess there would be a limit because if
you switched it on the hour people get
the [ __ ] out of here yeah yeah well what
if you decide that you like identify
with things that aren't even real like
elves does elf Kim it's a good point I
think I would if you just decide that
I'm an out but again if somebody came in
your office Peschel II if they were a
valuable employee right and they were
like I'm an elf mm-hmm and they had a
straight face right and and you're like
you're a high producer you're any
company okay but if someone comes in
your office and they're a woman
mm-hmm and they say today I'm a man yeah
today yes and I reserve the right to be
a woman back again tomorrow okay yeah
do you have penis no no just a man man
today mmm okay they'll let they're
letting you decide whether or not you're
gonna accept nonsense that's true I mean
here's the thing it's it's spreading
though it is growing yeah and it's
really a matter of how many people that
don't do that accept that this is a new
write reality well and then there's also
the thing that we all know is that some
people have an extreme desire to be
special without doing any work
whatsoever yeah they don't want to have
to work to be special they just want to
be special yeah
so if they can just say there's a lot of
them on Instagram yeah yeah they could
just say they're part of some
marginalized group then instantaneously
they get more respect and this is not
taking away from the people that I think
are legitimately trans I think there's
definitely people that illegitimate Lee
trainers I think those people that are
legitimately trans should be upset a
these gender-fluid [ __ ] weirdos
bouncing back and forth all day there's
a radio lab about that where the guy
decides during the conversation that
he's a man and then he's a woman I
switched over now I'm Paul
now I'm Eddie I just changed how do we
do not address that as 100% either
you're [ __ ] with me or you're
mentally ill right yeah you can't say
mentally ill when it comes to gender
that's the one area where mentally ill
like if it's violence yeah okay if it's
impulsive things like gambling or
something along those lines all that
stuff you could say you're mentally ill
yeah you cannot say you're mentally ill
when it comes to gender why because
we're scared we're scared of being
called out but if somebody is like I'm
talking right now and they switch and
they switch gender again they switch the
third and they switch the fourth time in
an hour conversation we're supposed to
just be like that's
[Applause]